eines der Themen von denen Eva Quadbeck
sagt das hat echt das Potenzial gerade
ihre grüne Partei richtig zu zu stressen
und zu spalten ist das große Thema
Migration warum glauben Sie das Rückwand
Weg ja weil das für die Grünen nach wie
vor ein identitätsthema ist dass sie
sagen die Grenzen in Europa müssen offen
sein Flüchtlinge die zu uns kommen ganz
klar dass verbriefte Grundrecht auf Asyl
für politisch Verfolgte woran in Teilen
der Union ja Moment gerüttelt wird also
der Ministerpräsident aus Sachsen möchte
eine Debatte darüber ob man sogar eine
Grundgesetzänderung herbeiführt und es
ist im Moment auch ein unterschätztes
Thema weil die Landes und die
Bundespolitiker nicht wirklich laut
darüber sprechen was in den Kommunen los
ist Landräte und Kommunalpolitiker tun
es immer wieder im Moment in der Sendung
werden hier grüne Landräte sitzen die
richtig Alarm geschlagen und sagen so
geht's nicht weiter wir sind heillos
überfordert richtig und die Asylzahlen
sind anders als der Kanzler ist pro
diagnostiziert nicht bei rund 200.000 im
Jahr sondern sie werden sehr viel höher
sein und selbst mit dem Asyl Kompromiss
der jetzt in der EU geschlossen wurde
und mit dem die Grünen ja ein großes
Problem haben und auch nachvollziehbar
ein Problem haben weil es natürlich im
Vergleich zu vorher keine sehr
humanitäre Lösung ist aber Europa weiß
ich im Moment eben auch nicht mehr
anders zu helfen weil man nicht genau
weiß wie man die Menschen aufnehmen kann
bei den Ländern die überhaupt noch
willig sind Menschen aufzunehmen also
diese Solidarität gibt es nicht und
obwohl es diesen Kompromiss in Europa
gibt ist das Problem in keinster Weise
gelöst und es kommen eben immer mehr und
sie als Ministerpräsident müssen ja
schon ihre Kommunen anweisen dass die
überhaupt noch Flüchtlinge aufnehmen sie
haben ja auch den Widerstand in ihrem
eigenen Land und zugleich gibt es auf
der Bundesebene diejenigen die sagen
selbst der EU asylkompromis der das
Problem wenn überhaupt nur in Teilen
lösen kann geht viel zu weit und man hat
das ja dann auch an dem Abend als der
Kompromiss geschlossen wurde gesehen die
Hälfte der Grünen Führungsmannschaft
sagt okay wir stützen das sind da
konform mit der Regierung und die andere
Hälfte sagt wir leben das ab
wo ist da ihre Position
Kompromiss stützt ganz eindeutig und ich
finde er ist von großer Bedeutung nach
vielen Jahren wo die EU einfach nicht
sich einigen konnte ist jetzt doch mal
ein minimal Kompromiss zustande gekommen
es ist ein sehr sehr guter Anfang ich
bin sehr sehr froh darüber denn gerade
wir in der Praxis wissen
nur Europa kann überhaupt einigermaßen
Ordnung
Klärung in dieses System bringen jeder
einzelne Nationalstaat ist damit
vollkommen überfordert es sei denn er
wirft eine humanitäre Flüchtlingspolitik
über Bord das wollen wir natürlich nicht
können und dürfen wir auch nicht und
darum bin ich froh über die Kompromiss
man muss sehen die sehr liberale
Flüchtlingspolitik der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland die wurde Grabmann noch
unterstützt von Luxemburg Portugal und
Irland das sind jetzt gerade nicht die
einflussstärksten
in Europa insofern kann man froh sein
dass diese Kompromiss zustande gekommen
wäre ich stelle mir mal vor wir hätten
den zusammen mit Polen und Ungarn
platzen lassen unvorstellbar
nur die Europäische Union kann
solidarisch dieses Problem
löst kann man es wahrscheinlich sowieso
nicht weil der migrationsdrucker der
sehr viel Stein aber dass man wenigstens
einigermaßen Ordnung
und Dinge tun muss die keiner tun ist
insofern finde ich die Zustimmung zu
diesem Kompromiss
richtig und ich bin im Gegenteil froh
darüber dass es endlich zu solch einen
Kompromissen Europa gekommen ist daran
kann man dann weiter bauen weiter war
sie sagten voll auch gerade sie hat
minimalergebnis dass wir da erzählt
haben das heißt ihnen geht das nicht
weit genug ja klar ich meine wir haben
ja jetzt noch keinen echten
verteilmechanismus
das heißt sie haben kein Problem damit
wenn er da Außengrenze der EU das heißt
ja dann im Zweifel auch zum Beispiel in
Nordafrika oder auch einen anderen
Stellen
Menschen dann ankommen die kommen dann
in wie auch immer wir es nennen nennen
wir es Zentren nennen wir es Gefängnis
die einen sagen das ist ein Zentrum die
anderen sagen da werden Menschen
monatelang wie in einem Gefängnis das
ist faktischen Knast werden dort
festgehalten das tun wir alles im Namen
einer humanitären europäischen
Asylpolitik na gut man kann so was
natürlich immer mit solchen verbal in
Syrien belegen ich versuche keine Haft
die Leute können ja zurück
er ist doch keine Haft sind haftähnliche
Zustände wenn Sie allerdings ist Land
wollen können Sie das nicht bis ihr
Verfahren abgeschlossen ist und das ist
gewährleistet die entscheidende Frage
ist doch ist das Asylrecht trotzdem
gewährleistet das ist jedenfalls mal so
vereinbarten und muss auch umgesetzt
werden und es geht doch letztlich darum
dass wir brauchen Einwanderung und
wollen Einwanderung wir müssen die
Arbeitsmigration legalisieren und die
irreguläre Migration eindämmen das ist
strategisch das was wir machen müssen
wir brauchen ja Menschen sozusagen von
der Küche in der Gastwirtschaft bis zu
it-cracks wir brauchen die diese
Migration müssen wir erleichtern damit
den Leuten eine Perspektive entsteht
aber irreguläre müssen wir eindämmen
denn wir wissen auch die die gar keinen
Anspruch auf Asyl haben
die bleiben ja trotzdem ewig hier dann
entstehen die Probleme die wir haben
darum geht es nicht das Asylrecht
einzuschränken sondern dafür zu sorgen
dass die hierher kommen die echte
Fluchtursachen haben ich will nur mal
sagen warum gibt es ja sozusagen von der
anderen Seite Kritik an dem Kompromiss
Syrien
Afghanistan zum Beispiel die sind ja
davon gar nicht betroffen sondern nur
Länder sollte man das bei denen
Erkennungsquote sollte darauf ausweiten
sollte man das auf Syrien und
Afghanistan ausweiten nein ich meine das
sind ja Länder wo die Fluchtursachen
berechtigt und sehr groß sind und da
müssen die die Leute wirklich
einfachere Möglichkeiten haben dass
diese deutsche Gesellschaft irgendwann
sagt das können wir nicht mehr darum
sage ich ja verstehen sie wenn wir zum
Schluss des einzigen Landes in Europa
mit einer liberalen
Flüchtlingspolitik dann wollen ja alle
dahin ist ja jetzt schon dass die
meisten nach Deutschland wollen
irgendwann Platz ist doch klar wenn alle
anderen eher zu machen wie die einzigen
die es nicht machen dann irgendwann
funktioniert es nicht mehr deswegen ist
dieser Kompromiss so wichtig weil es der
Beginn wir haben den Beginn dessen dass
alle Verantwortung übernehmen müssen da
bin ich noch nicht zufrieden keine Frage
aber es ist immerhin ein Anfang gemacht
die Vorstellung in Europa liegen
weitauseinander und ich will noch mal
zusammenfassend sagen der Kompromiss ist
das Schicksal Europas anders kann es
nicht erfolgreich agieren
im Moment ist es aber ein Kompromiss auf
dem Papier also das ist das große
Problem die Umsetzung ist die große
Herausforderung
und in der in der grünen Partei sind das
ganz viele ganz ganz anders Jürgen
Trittin hat sich zu Wort gemeldet er
sagte diese deutsche Zustimmung war
falsch
Ricarda lang hat sich zu Wort gemeldet
wir hätten nicht zustimmen dürfen werden
eine aminata Touré hier ich glaube wir
haben das sogar kurz vorbereitet
vielleicht können wir einmal kurz rein
jemand von der ganz anderen Seite der
ganz ganz anders argumentiert immerhin
die zuständige Ministerin genau für
Migration in Schleswig-Holstein bitte
schön ich wünsche mir an aller erster
Stelle das europäischen Einigung gibt
aber nicht zu dem Preis dass man keine
Einigung findet die wir auch politisch
immer wieder gefordert haben die eben
human ist und die eben sich durchaus mit
der Frage auseinandersetzt
verpflichtende verteidquoten zu haben im
Interesse der anderen Staaten aber auch
im Interesse der Menschen damit sie eben
nicht in überfüllten Lagern an den
EU-Außengrenzen so ich finde es
unmöglich und ich finde es
menschenrechtlich bedenklich wenn wir
Menschen inhaftieren an den europäischen
Außengrenzen die Monate lang in solchen
Lagern dann wären und dann erst die
Situation haben dass sie möglicherweise
ist noch Null sicher dass das
tatsächlich eine Verteilung dann
stattfindet
in human wenn wir Menschen inhaftieren
wenn wir haftzentral auffalls Gegenteil
dessen was sie gerade vorgetragen haben
ich sehe es ebenso wie ich es sehe
dürfen sie auch wenn aber wie groß ist
die Gefahr dass es ist da wirklich
zerreißt glaube ich nicht ich meine muss
sehen die Annalena baerburg ist ja jetzt
nicht gerade für eine restriktive
Flüchtlingspolitik bekannt es wäre mal
ganz neu jetzt kann man sehen wenn so
eine Person solch ein Kompromiss
zustimmt dann wird sie wohl gute Gründe
dafür haben man muss doch sehen die
Position in Europa liegen enorm
auseinander jetzt ist damit begonnen
worden die zusammenzubringen und allen
ist klar wenn das nicht geschehen wäre
hätten wir auf Jahre oder dass ich immer
mehr verschärfen und zum Schluss macht
jeder Wasser will und vielleicht ist es
schenken dann noch in Gefahr und und wir
machen wieder Grenzkontrolle es kann
doch nicht Interesse von uns sein wir
haben gesehen der exit war schon ein
schwerer Schlag mit den Folgen die das
alles hatte vor allem jetzt für die
Briten die sehen ist und wir müssen
wieder daran bauen dass Europa
handlungsfähig ist und es muss in dieser
wichtigen Frage handlungsfähig bleiben
denn wir sind nicht allein auf der Welt
besteht in dem harten Wettbewerb mit
China und den USA und deswegen brauchen
wir ein stabiles handlungsfähiges Europa
auch in dieser Frage und der Beginn ist
mit dem Kompromiss gemacht letzte Frage
zu dem Themenkomplex sichere
Herkunftsländer gerade in ihrer grünen
Partei Moldau und Georgien sind für sie
sichere Herkunftsländer
also ob etwas ein sicheres Herkunftsland
ist oder so entscheidend nicht ich das
ist Aufgabe der Bundesregierung die
Bundesregierung hat Botschaften ja die
kann die Verhältnisse beurteilen also
juristisch gesagt die Bundesregierung
hat die Prärogative zu entscheiden ist
das erst wenn sie das einbringt
dann befasse ich mich damit aber auch
nur ob das plausibel ist denn ich habe
keine Botschafter ich kann das erstmal
gar nicht beurteilen es ist Aufgabe der
Bundesregierung und so habe ich es
damals schon gemacht das prüfe ich ob
das plausibel ist und wenn das plausibel
ist dann stimme ich dem zu okay also sie
würden dem zustimmen wenn es schlimm
wenn
man seit Jahren Pragmatismus ja ist das
Thema der Stunde
Maghreb-Staaten Marokko Tunesien
Algerien sicherer Herkunftsländer oder
nicht für Sie das muss die
Bundesregierung entscheiden muss sie
kann das entscheiden nur sie hat die
Mittel und die Instrumente um das
überhaupt zu Brief ich vermisse 2017
Zeitung lesen kann ich natürlich auch
aber darauf kann ich doch keine
Entscheidung fällen
schauen Sie die Bundesregierung 2017
wollten sie wollten sie genau der
Ausweitung der sicheren Bundesländer
auch Maghreb Staaten zustimmen für den
Fall dass die Bundesregierung zustimmt
sie hätten es gemacht nein
Plausibilität nicht also wenn schon bei
beeinst eine Länder das schon fordern
dass die und die Staaten
sichere Herkunftsländer sind dann möchte
ich mal wissen woher wissen die das ich
meine nur die Bundesregierung hat ein
Auswärtiges Amt sie hat die Instrumente
um das zu prüfen sie hat die Leute in
diesem Land die kann das untersuchen das
ist doch deren Job
aber Menschen haben auch ein
Hausverstand also ich war kürzlich
selber in Moldau und der Republik Moldau
unterwegs wie es offiziell heißt da
können wir beide morgen hinfliegen da
gibt es Menschen in ihrer Partei die
sagen das ist kein sicheres
Herkunftsland
verstehen sie das mal sie bringen mich
vor meiner Linie nicht ab es ist eine
Aufgabe der Bundesregierung das
entscheidet sie und dann wenn es
prinzipiels ein und dann prüfe ich als
Landesregierung ob das plausibel ist
oder nicht und dann stimme ich zu oder
nicht 2 17 7217 als zugestimmt das meine
ich doch äh die Ländern der kritisiert
jetzt das hinterher dass es falsch war
habe ich ernsthaft nicht gehört also
jeder kann sich darauf verlassen dass
ich schon sorgfältig prüfe ist es sind
das belastbare Aussage
und ihre Partei genau bei dem Thema z.B
das ist doch einer der Gründe warum die
AFD auch einen solchen Zulauf hat genau
diese Diskussion immer geführt werden
Bucht jemand ein Urlaub fliegt nach
Marokko
klapp-weg Wecker
marokkanische Wurzeln ganz genau wir
könnten jetzt morgen dahin fliegen und
dann kommen Teil aus ihr coolen Partei
und sagen gut ihr könnt das zwar Urlaub
machen aber an sicherer Herkunftsland
ist das und dann kann der größte Quatsch
also ich finde diese Themen also jetzt
als einfachste Bürgerin nicht als
Wissenschaftlerin
Flüchtlingspolitik Klimaschutzpolitik
Finanzierungspolitik sind dermaßen
moralisch und ethisch überladen und ich
finde die Kritik an diesen Politiken
muss muss gerade eben aus der Mitte
herauskommen damit eben die Ränder nicht
gestärkt werden damit so etwas weder bei
heizungsgesetz passiert noch bei der
Flüchtlingspolitik ich würde sagen
fühle ich mich nicht bedroht sondern
weil natürlich nicht wo in jede was in
allen Ecken noch passiert aber ich würde
jetzt in Nordafrika eher also wie gesagt
Sie haben recht das muss ein Auswärtiges
Amt auch aus der deutschen Perspektive
bewerten aber ich finde es ist richtig
dass ein Kompromiss auf die EU-Ebene
gefunden wurde der einfach gesagt wir
wollen das regeln es kann nicht jeder
kommen es können nicht alle hierher
kommen aber wir wollen das wenigstens
Regeln irreguläre und reguläre das ist
der Punkt und ich finde wenn das aber
moralisch überladen wird dann ist das
dann ist das gut dass die Diskussion um
so ein Thema mit sehr viel Schamgefühl
beladen und das darf nicht sein das ist
das Gefühl was dann die Leute bekommen
ich darf nichts mehr dazu sagen und so
weiter also aber ich finde ich finde
jetzt Marokko Tunesien Entschuldigung
sind keine unsicheren Länder jetzt im
Vergleich zu Syrien oder Afghanistan
bitte das ist überhaupt kein Vergleich
ich weiß nicht wie Sie das sehen herr
Kretschmann was erklären natürlich hat
mir das damals enorme Kritik eingebracht
ich würde mal sagen es hat mir meine
Partei eine nicht verziehen dass ich
damals zugestimmt habe so ich muss mich
dann Auseinandersetzen mit den Gründen
was was warten eigentlich der Grund
jeder dachte sichere Herkunftsländer
kriegst du kein Asyl mehr wenn du daher
kommst das ist aber falsch bestimmt
überhaupt richtig auch das ist Asylrecht
ist dafür nicht eingeschränkt die
Verfahren sind schneller und vereinbar
aber jeder denkt er hat sichere
Herkunftsländer da darf gar keine mehr
kommen und das kriegen sie einfach
schwer durch kommuniziert weil das wäre
Partei kriegen das ist natürlich
kommunizieren Druck als ist damit das
Asylrecht gekennzeichnet der Fall und
auch jetzt bei der Debatte ja um diese
Lager muss das Asylrecht gewährleisten
durchgesetzt und die Leute müssen einen
Rechtsbeistand bekommen das ist nachher
würde ich auch gemacht wird
verhandeln können sie erstmal nur Papier
das ist eine ganz andere Frage darauf
müssen die Institutionen dann achten
also aber auch gegen Stimmung und man
muss sich aber immer bei Entscheidungen
jedenfalls ich die Verantwortung tragen
auf Tatsachen müssen und nicht auf
irgendwelche
wie wir wie wir Europa und auch die
Fähigkeit Europas kennen schwierige
Entscheidungen schnell umzusetzen ist ja
ziemlich klar dass das nicht schnell
funktionieren wird und was eben nicht
gelungen ist man hat sich ja gar nicht
geeinigt also wie diejenigen die dann
tatsächlich in Europa Asyl bekommen
sollen verteilt werden also da gibt es
ja nach wie vor keine Solidarität und
die Länder die an den Außengrenzen sind
und wo die Flüchtlinge ankommen die sind
ja auch jetzt schon tatsächlich sehr
belastet und haben entsprechende
Stimmung entsprechende
rechtspopulistische Strömungen in ihrem
Land Regierungen und entsprechende
Regierung und ob die überhaupt in der
Lage sind solche Lager will ich jetzt
mal sagen zu haben die Menschen dort zu
versorgen und diese Verfahren
durchzuführen bisher machen die das ja
gar nicht also bisher wird ja auch das
was man vereinbart hat das Dublin
Abkommen überhaupt nicht angewendet das
nämlich eigentlich im Land wo sie
ankommen die Verfahren sein sollen die
werden ja tatsächlich alle durchgewunken
und kommen überwiegend in Deutschland an
und dass ich das auf einmal rumdreht
dass das glaube ich wirklich erst wenn
ich sehe wenn es gemacht wird ich ich
sehe zwar diesen Kompromiss und ich
halte ihn auch im Moment für richtig
aber ich gebe dem relativ Ringe geringe
Chancen auf Umsetzung und wir sind ja in
einem echten dilemm ne wenn man sich
anschaut heute vor dem Peloponnes gab es
offenbar ein schweres Schiffsunglück 70
tote möglicherweise auch deutlich mehr
zusammengefert über 400 Menschen an Bord
genau eines solchen Schiffes so dass
ertragen wir nicht solche Bilder das
dürfen wir auch nicht zulassen das
wollen wir auf gar keinen Fall und
gleichzeitig müssen wir regeln einziehen
ja Humanität und Ordnung nur wenn wir
beides zusammenbringen hat es eine
Chance das eine wie das andere nicht und
nur in diesem
Zusammenspiel von
Ordnung und humanitität kriegt man das
überhaupt hin denn wir müssen doch mal
realistisch sehen der Migrationsdruck
wird der zunehmen allein schon durch den
Klimawandel nicht und da müssen schauen
dass wir einigermaßen Handlungsfähigkeit
ist und ich finde jeder Staat für sich
merkt doch selbst die Italiener haben
das gemerkt nicht das ist ja nun jetzt
eine Regierung die richtig aus dem
hardcorechten Lager kommt selbst die
merken sie kommen allein nicht weiter
und Sie müssen sich in der Europäischen
Union kommen Mitten ähm das ist doch
erstmal ein erfreuliches Ergebnis das
soll selbst solche Regierung die mit
Europa
gekommen ist jetzt in der Realität merkt
wir uns gemeinsam
Zukunft
reinzubringen und uns grün ist natürlich
Humanität bei der Flüchtlingspolitik ein
absolutes Herzensanliegen und das müssen
wir machen eigentlich wiederholen mich
aber strategisch müssen wir deswegen die
Arbeitsmigration erleichtern und zwar
auch für Leute die noch nicht gut
Deutsch können aber die wir brauchen
damit die Leute eine Perspektive haben
und nicht immer den Weg wählen obwohl
sie gar nicht politisch verfolgt sind
über das Asylsystem zu kommen in der
Hoffnung wenn sie lang gesucht da sind
dann bleiben genau der Punkt das ist
genau der Punkt politisch Verfolgte
müssen immer das Recht haben auf also
aber alles andere muss man Regeln für
Arbeit